hello
hello
are we live
i need a hello emote
i think we
are it's really hard to tell sometimes
hi louis
zombie rusty
miss ma
hello everyone
oh we do have chat doesn't look very
good hold on
hold everybody hold
[Music]
wow
that's a lot
you know everyone's the same color
anyway
that'll be fine
how is everybody doing this fine tuesday
got a rage shadow legend ad before this
very nice excellent
that means we're monetized i love that
no not skin i mean the chat in the top
right corner
love your voice i'm glad you like it
because i hate my voice
yeah i'm doing great thank you for
asking zombie
amazeballs
been a minute since i caught you dying
to malacath
dude that
that was pretty nuts we were on malacath
for like two hours the other day
do you believe that this is a big bowl
of cereal
i think there's a lot going on here that
i really haven't thought of um
that i'd like to show you guys or talk
to you guys about
yeah gideon took a while too i don't
they definitely
definitely
updated gideon he's ridiculous now like
actually a difficult boss
but the camera's going to go
yep i don't know where i am now
here i am
yes very moldy cereal
indeed
i was i was getting footage
just in this area i think i was getting
footage of the fire giant
i just like to go through the game and
record like cinematic shots a lot kind
of gets me inspired to do things and
then sometimes i see some weird [ __ ]
i'm like whoa what is that
that's kind of where these streams come
from
spicy it's a spicy cereal
so
i was going up this chain or actually
going back down the chain from the wrong
direction right
just to start this off
i looked over here
i saw this thing right
and at first like first glance and i i
know it's not but first glance what does
that look like right there
this uh pillar
everybody say it about the bird
i want a burp
do i have the thing on
oh it looks
better
yeah it kind of looks like a divine
tower right this thing
which we can get a way closer look at
way closer look
with our camera mod
look at this thing
yo it's bones
becoming an outer god
for five months straight thank you bro
you are amazing
hello bones how you doing man good to
see you been a while
hi hi hi
yeah kind of small though right like i
looked at it closer i'm like nah that's
not a divine tower
it's very small i'm not saying this
right here is a divine tower but i
started looking close at it
i can actually adjust the lighting
hold on
like get a better look at it
if there is good lighting on this i'm
not even sure there we go
that's a little bit better
okay
but thank you again bones that's really
really freaking nice of you bro
yeah i'm smelling the lore there's
definitely smelling going on here
i like talking to talking about it with
you guys though it's a lot more fun
and there's these like uh design
patterns on
on the side of it
right
not even sure what this is
it's like a baby divine tower
maybe
um then i looked at this side right here
you notice this like uh kind of
bulgy
i don't know what to call it just like
kind of weird growths or bulges kind of
coming out of it like it just cut it's a
weird part of it like on this side as
well
you know what i'm saying
which really reminds me of the divine
towers
like a lot
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
that is a hundred dollar super chat oh
my god
damn
thank you bones holy [ __ ]
outer gods no joke either
get some w's in the chat for bones my
god
thank you dude
holy crap
[Laughter]
that that's a lot thank you man
w's in the chat
this w's comes out of nowhere all the
time just
does stuff like that i really appreciate
it dude
don't get it twisted
thank you that's insane
i keep saying thank you a hundred
million times because uh yeah
i don't know what i'll say
w's in the chat thank you
uh so these bulges on the side and
to uh
talk a little bit more about these
bulges
i talked about it in a uh
my first
interesting discoveries
let's go to the isolated divine tower
is that there are these bulges on the
side of the divine towers
and it's always on one particular side
this right here
you see that
it's like this
i don't know what to call it
it's like a bulge
there's something growing on the side of
it right
and every divine tower has these
i'm not entirely sure what to make of
them
these bulges so that's what kind of got
me like man i wonder if these are
if this forge up here could potentially
potentially
[Music]
be
somewhat of a divine tower that's that's
definitely not the only thing we look at
here
it's not bark it's it looks like it's
still stone we can look at it more
but a parasite is a great way to look at
it
so then i started looking closer at
the forge right first thing
that pops out are the chains right like
we come up
to the forge on this chain
right here and then i'm like wait
there's
there's two other change chains
look a bit closer at that
what were these connected to at one
point right
this right here
it had to have been connected to
something at some point
look down
and out what are you talking about
i don't know what you're talking about
massive earthquake
then there's this chain right here
so
the other part of it
let me see what you guys are saying
first i don't want to just like spit out
a whole bunch of [ __ ]
it has an area to pour stuff out just
like a crucible
an area to pour stuff out
carved out of stone
it does look like a crucible
i don't know what what do you mean by
that
the top of the vine towers have the same
number of walls as the eyes of the fel
god
same number of walls
you're saying these gaps right here are
natural like they were made that way
the chunk you're looking at now is where
molten metal would be poured out of the
crucible
poured out in a crucible
you think this or you know this
it looks broken to me
like it wasn't meant to be like this
i could be wrong
you think it okay gotcha i didn't know
if you had like something out there that
like literally says that or not
i mean we look at this side right here
something scraped through this right
that's what it looks like to me it looks
broken like this was not supposed to
look like this
this looks scraped right here
it has a distinct color
you guys see like that little golden hue
in it
the same over here
yeah look at that that doesn't look
natural at all from this side
it looks like claws
digged into it
right
for sure right here
that'll look right
i don't know about this gap but
something clawed the [ __ ] out of this
thing
so it makes me think of the dragons and
then what really calls to that is this
right here
i mean why are the hooks to the forge
have this like dragon emblem on it
not sure which dragon this is
giant ice dragon
why an ice dragon
high neurone
the dragons built it
well it makes me
it's so hard to tell
so let me just go on like everything
that i was finding yesterday and then we
can kind of go from there okay
there's also these um
designs on sort of the bottom over here
is this the face of anything
that you guys know of
do you see a face here because i
definitely do it's like
one eye to eye something it could be a
mask
is it the fel god
that's what i was wondering
hey shaky what's up
why you guys say riker
yeah it could be a mess but it
definitely looks like a face
[Music]
i gotta
maybe it's the fel god okay i mean we
can look at some i have every item on
this character
uh
is there something that kind of looks
like that that you can think of an item
the lion turtle
from
from avatar
we are primed to recognize faces even
though there's nothing there that's
that's a good point
the one eye shield
these are ashes of war and not weapons
i just go right over it
oh there's like an actual shield tab
this one
uh
[Music]
i wish you could zoom in on these
i don't think it's this one
kind of same stone structure though
actually i could put it on
let's go to fire monk armor
fire milk armor
oh i wish you could search
uh
let me put this [ __ ] on so that we can
look at like me you know what i mean
i'm not seeing a major similarity
let me look at it again
um
do you guys see it
i'm i'm not
yeah this one definitely looks different
i'm gonna go ahead and say no
so you guys see reichardt i've seen a
lot of people say reichardt really
what is the best picture of him is it
just in volcano manor
i feel like there's another one
downstairs somewhere
that has a different picture of him
give me that
are you guys saying in his serpent form
you're saying his snake face
oh no i think i already killed him
no i didn't
hold maybe i have i don't know stealth
so we can look at him
uh
yeah i already killed him
well actually she's eating his face
gross
does this help
hard to control
opposites
ignore tanith
and her loud chewing
i already have her stuff without killing
her
i'm not seeing it
i'm really not
what i did want to show though just to
go off of what you guys are are doing
what you're
what i was saying earlier
let's look at the face one more time
ingrain it in the brain
i need to do the same
it's like a mcdonald's nuggie
all right
ingrain this in your brain okay
we're gonna get into that dark
i think the isolated divine tower may
have been connected to this forge at one
point
i also have some like a theory that uh
pharah missoula did as well
but we'll talk about it
ingraining this in my brain
i'm not seeing fire giant with this
either
look at the figure upside down
that's something
trying to go down
i see a smile
right like that
it's hard to control
pot of greed is that a thing
[Laughter]
goomba
right card
i'm really not seeing riker but um
i mean you guys are saying enough to at
least point it out so
oh it's [ __ ] from yu-gi-oh all right
the one show i didn't watch
i didn't watch pokemon either don't kill
me all right so
remember the face
it's like a wolf
okay so where did i see these
look at it yesterday
is that it
no
i summon pot of greed
and i also summon
pot of greed
i have seen the meme though i think it's
down below hold
this is another thing you guys need to
remember right here
i did watch beyblade
this uh
oh
there we are
what
we need to go back and look at the other
things
i need to look on the outside of the
tower
[Music]
you guys see it right there it is
that's literally it right there
on the divine tower
yup
yup joker face and all
there's a face below it as well
[Music]
i wanted to make sure i was spot on let
me change the lighting
same texture seems like
it's darker
the side might not get good light
doesn't look like it okay
this is better
[Music]
that is the same base
maybe with more definition
no i'm just looking at everything
okay so
we have a clear connection i think
to the forge of the giants and the at
least this divine tower but i'm i'm like
99 sure all the divine towers look like
this
for the most part right at least on the
outside
so there's one connection
the next one
is this
star pattern right
for the
i would call it just a divine tower lift
right or not a star a flower i think i
said flower
um
you guys see the flower pattern here
right like with the petals around
the middle section that you stand on
yeah i'm not making any assumptions yet
i'm just gonna put everything out there
right yeah it's like a lotus flower it's
definitely a flower pattern
if we go to the malacath boss room
which i think he's still here
i might have to eat him out of the way
yeah he's still here being a forehead
yeah i know we're back here
okay he won't spawn here
because i killed him while i'm in the
room
it doesn't look the same but i'll show
you in a second don't don't make any uh
don't say nothing yet
this to me looks like a lift of some
kind that we're gonna see
i think potentially in a future dlc
where we'll hit this lift and it'll take
us somewhere else like this just looks
like a button you [ __ ] stand on to me
it definitely is not the sunflower
that i think i found
in a really odd spot he's going to be
lagging here because we're not actually
looking at him
look at that
pretty interesting right this camera
lets us see stuff
that we never
ever see
it's definitely a flower
you see a face
it's not the same flower though is it
also not straight
six petals on this one eight on the
other
where do you guys see a face
i see a mask above the flower right here
this thing
maybe
what is this this looks like a stem
them
my esses are awful
into a flower
that has like a mask over it you're kind
of right i definitely see that now
interesting
the er trees roots
sure
this looks like a lift to me
god i wish you could step on this and
go somewhere
flowers are on gwen's armor
interesting
far above the lift
is interesting
it's like this up here
look at this
i remember looking at this yesterday
like there's
like why did they grid this out
you can even see the clipping
there's no one to ever be here
it kind of looks like where a elevator
would be right
with
sort of the same symbol
kinda
it's hard to tell because they're
clipping this all together like they
didn't even clip it perfectly you can
see that right there
i don't think anything's up here
remember looking through here yesterday
yeah
there ain't nothing
here but it does go straight down
right here
pattern in the middle is the flower from
the divine tower
so i think the next thing below the lift
is just nothing it's just darkness
just to show that real quick
nothing
pure darkness this right here is
something i'm really curious about
um
who
who has three wolves
i always think ratagon
but i think he has more than three
i think he has four
i don't want to get on to something else
yet
just bringing this up for what we can
talk about later
cry
going up again and look at the
look at middle of the floor didn't we do
that
looks like selling
really
the spirit ashes ronnie gives you
three wolves
let's talk about that later all right
we'll come back here remind me to come
back later i don't want to get
distracted by something else because
we're on the divine towers right now
but
i think there is very clear
uh
why can't i
leave sun up beach
i think there's a very clear
comparisons to the divine tower in the
forge of the giants now the next thing
we would need to talk about with that
is did
the people who made the forge or whoever
it is like however they came to be
were they is it just the same architect
or
is it something else right god damn it
how do i get out of here
i just want to hit him
ronnie and the other demigods are a lot
younger than ferrum
i think you're right on that
do we know that for sure though
do we
that might not be true
because ronnie isn't
like a person anymore she's a spirit
radon has been roaming around for
what could potentially be thousands of
years all of these demigods have been
they just keep saying an age ago and we
don't really know what that is
and then reichard's a
giant snake so who knows how long they
live for
missoula is the era where placidus x
was a eldon lord though
i think you're right
that is true
when was that though
because it's our understanding that
why can't i leave this area
i don't have a warp thing right now
we're gonna have malakath kill me
i don't want to turn on my other mod
it's gonna be a lot of work
[Music]
i think i have to reload again sorry
before the crucible
so what came first guys the crucible or
the dragons i mean is it just like dark
souls where the dragons were first
why is he not attacking me i don't have
stealth on
oh it's because i'm in the room
can i jump
that'll work
dragons
some of you saying dragons some of you
saying crucible
[Music]
[Music]
attack me
all right i gotta turn on my mod
um
kind of screwed myself here
is there a way for me to warp the [ __ ]
out of here
know how to work my own mods
wow you actually get stuck in here
all right turn it on the other mod
uh
gotta hide this for a minute
one second
yeah now we're all talking about a whole
bunch of other stuff
we gotta we gotta focus boys
we gotta focus
there we go
blah blah this is me i'm sorry
warp
out of here excellent
that's me
all right there we go
okay
i don't think i'll need that but we'll
keep it up
sexy yes i'm in a tank top
wow this is pretty
i have not gotten ready today at all i
just wanted to stream
imagine if i was like shirtless
[Music]
press the wrong video capture
the crucible either precedes the dragons
and the ferrum civilization
or they are complementary
maybe an age ago is when time came to
exist
so you guys are suggesting like
now we're even more distracted
you guys are suggesting that potentially
time started at one point
i guess that's true
for everything
i suppose that's getting deep with it
bro i'm just seeing the connection here
between the divine towers and
this forge
what
do you guys think that the forge could
be a divine tower
and also
i'm gonna go ahead and say why did a
big ass dragon
what did he do to this thing
why did he do this
he or she i don't know why did it do
this
this looks like a dragon with a big ass
claw just like ripped it out of one side
and the other
could it be placa do sacks
is that how you say his name
i've heard people say it in
many different ways i say place to do
sex
you think it's grand sex
or sacks i don't think fortisacks is big
enough to do that
i think it's a bigger dragon than even
placidus axe
another um
i'm saying this could be a divine tower
just because of the the very similar
designs
look the face is even right here
that we saw in the um
at the divine tower right
so either from software is reusing
assets for different things in different
locations
which
i don't really believe that i think
thought goes into all of this because of
like literally what we're doing right
now
or they're connected
clearly connected to the dragons in some
way with this
i think it was connected to at least two
other things at one point with these
giant chains
on the sides
but have since been ripped off
right
even these pillars right here remind me
very much of a divine tower
but this leads up into a nice big cereal
bowl
that that would that's what i was
thinking unknown that it do you guys
think that this forge at one point
held pharah missoula in place
potentially
and then was ripped off
by these chains
because this is a pretty significant
like i'm not gonna say that
doubt it no
doesn't make sense
would that connect to caled
something
i mean the other the other obvious thing
is that why are we put in pharah
missoula right after we light this up
i think there are like
with all this that we were talking about
clear connections with the forge of the
giants the divine towers and pharah
missoula
we should look at cut content because
elden ring is structured like multiple
cataclysms happen
yeah the mel in a teleport that's what i
mean
barum's a prison for place to do sex
right
so but his followers imprisoned him in
time so that he isn't
it wasn't it so plastidusaks could meet
their fell god
right
[Laughter]
and malakath really
i didn't see it as malacath being
imprisoned in any way
yeah he's waiting for his lord to return
i'm not sure the use of prison is the
right word
i think he's there on his own
but i mean everyone makes the point like
when we go to pharah missoula
it's not
we're in the same how do how do i even
put this this game is so hard to
describe things
is the entirety of pharah missoula in a
different time frame
or is it just
the place of deus ex arena
i think it's just the arena
because when we lay down
we enter
a different like time shifts
right
why is that
why when we lay down in that spot do are
we transported back
do we know if it's back
that's the other thing
it is it forward or back
the storm brings us there
i mean we clearly see time shift like
things stop things are put back together
you know what i'm saying
plucked out of time i mean let's watch
the cutscene maybe this will
trigger something i have no idea let's
go lay in the spot where's the good uh
here
[Music]
we have to go down yeah
let's look at the cutscene
the storm is beyond time i remember
reading that
which i can only imagine is a single
moment frozen forever
you know what i'm doing for this [ __ ]
hold on more modding please
uh ride anywhere thank god for this mod
please
why not
why not
i have to rest with the work
i'm not running all the way down there
click
what if we're the reincarnation of
mycolo i mean you guys really want to
get into that
we'll talk about a lot of stuff today
man
let's focus on one thing at a time
hey look at this right here is this not
the lift in the middle of malachite's
room
this is the exact design
[Music]
that thing is totally a lift and it's
going to take us somewhere i know it
exactly the same
yup
yup
we are all michela
yep
oh this is so much nicer
all right can we look at this real quick
why is it
when i lay right there
that we move in time why
what is this
what are you
this whole thing was the arena
this whole thing right here was the
arena
so that means plastiducex is there
and then we are taken through time
let's just watch it because this is put
back together
i've gone in the middle of the storm
with this camera and there's nothing
there
time is stopped
the rocks are moving in the opposite
direction that they were just moving in
so this looks like it's back
time reversal
hillaries are put back together
yeah this entire arena
was where
we are about to be taken
the arena is up in the storm
i mean can we see that from down there
are you just saying that
there's all those graves
this is so badass
did he notice you and invites you in if
that's the case why does he try to kill
us
also you guys notice this same golden
hue all over his body
that we were talking about with the
scratches in the side of the forge
it's like that same color pattern
i don't think he's big enough to make
those though
i've done this before
hmm
i'll go down in a sec
that same like golden hue pattern
did godfrey do this was it wasn't it
godfrey that uh cut off his other heads
big golden ass eye
right we got that description that
placidus x was
the original elden lord
and then his god left him
then the golden order took over
okay you said go down
wait
looking at patterns
okay going down
[Music]
looks like a [ __ ] planet
okay so i get what you're saying
that
we could be way up in
the sky
right
this could just be from software taking
us somewhere else
right like away from the arena just to
like not have all the other assets
loaded in why are these here though
does that make sense
there's the fog gate that they have to
have no matter where we are
this is where we enter this is like the
dragon that's like hanging off the side
of it
it's just not loaded in
the arena's there
i mean if we go way below
or way above into the storm are we gonna
see this there i don't think so
does it look like a clock
this
a clock you say
where are you getting clock
what are these
it's dead bodies
looks like a clock from beneath
he has 24 pillars
one two three four
seven 10 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20.
one two three
it has 20 pillars
i'm counting 20 not 24.
also who knows what [ __ ] time is you
know
like do they really say like oh it's 10
a.m
what about here
10 am guys time to eat breakfast i don't
know
i don't think this world works
like it does here get close enough we
can't do close enough man
we say close enough people go no
wrong
all right i gotta do this for me
i just gotta do it i don't think
anyone's gonna complain are you
i love the music in this fight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
had to do it
now we get a really good look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi
okay
[Music]
imagine
[Music]
[Music]
have any of you guys played little
nightmares
[Music]
because this song reminds me of the last
song in that game
in little nightmares too
[Music]
too scared for horror games
the game is pretty [ __ ] scary
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that killed me all right whatever
i just wanted to listen to his music
[Music]
i had no idea how much health i had or
how much he had
all right
going back to it
i don't think we found much in there
can we agree that there's some
some type of connection between pharah
missoula divine towers and the forge of
the giants
fourth of the giants is how we're sent
here
divine tower has some like very very
similar
designs on it
compared to the forge of the giants
i don't know how you can say no also
your [ __ ] profile picture is a kappa
so
never mind
not pharam i mean we're literally sent
here
from the forge
that's redunk
absolutely redonk
or girl i have every weapon in the game
on this character
good point how did the how was the
draconic tree sentinel here
what the what the [ __ ] are you doing
here
i'm not saying they built it i'm saying
there's gotta be some connections right
what is that
he's guarding out yeah why is it a
draconic tree sentinel
guardian malakath
the twin birds
is that an item i don't know about
they do look like birds
dragons disagreed
twin bird shield
okay
i don't know what it looks like so hold
yes
you are not wrong
it's like they're facing each other
oh it's upside down wait
oh
god hold on
yeah we'll read the description
let me get rid of this
look at that
that's very similar to what's above
very similar to what's above the uh
the boss arena back there
shield featuring a vividly painted twin
bird quinbird is said to be the envoy
of an outer god and mother of the death
birds
slightly boost attack and defense
the shield slightly okay
mother of the death birds
i mean he is protecting destin death in
there so
it looks like it to me man i ain't gonna
cap
that looks
really similar
not exactly
but i think similar enough to definitely
draw a comparison to it
there i am
that's all sunny
hmm
it's it's similar enough to mention i i
think so too that's a that's a really
interesting discovery man
i don't know if this has been talked
about before
but that is clearly
i would say
very similar
very very very much so
our drag wait
this might be a dumb question i don't
know that much about dragons um are
dragons considered birds
i haven't really thought of that before
i know they can fly
what's the thing in the middle
dude i must say something that might be
dumb is that the forge
this
that looks like the [ __ ] forge man
like a bowl
it's alexander
okay
are the chains so let's say that this
might let's say that
hypothetically that this is the forge
were the chains holding these birds
two chains are broken
on the forge
and they said they
what does the shield say again
do i really have to go into inventory to
read item descriptions
still
come on dog
said to be the envoy of an outer god and
mother of the death birds
don't the beastman summons mention that
pharah missoula was a mausoleum that
housed the corpses of an ancient dragon
beastman summons you said
he's been peaceful
spirits of beastman from doomed pharah
missoula the slowly con crumbling ruins
in the skies
the ruins are said to be of the remains
of an ancient mausoleum enshrined
in ancient dragon
guarded by chosen beastmen who wielded
weapons clad in light
is that talking about
hmm
it's got to be talking about plastiducex
check heads in the forge
what do you i don't know what that means
the heads
oh you're saying the dragons
are you saying this is like one of the
twin dragons and then this one is the
other
dude
that's the forge
inferior missoula
between the two dragons
right
that's how this like design is is kind
of captured
son of a [ __ ]
by the way when you're down there
nothing's loaded in nothing is real
everything's a simulation
okay
guys look out your window wherever
you're right now where wherever you are
right now at school at home wherever you
are you're looking around a corner it
doesn't exist it's not there
it's not loaded in yet but once you look
at it it'll load in anyway get off topic
of that
that looks like one head that's another
head that's the forge
although these look like [ __ ] birds
gorge is very tiny
these do look weird
they definitely look different from
dragons but
i mean what does it look like on here
these have beaks dude
these literally have beaks
those are some goddamn beaks dude
so they're twin birds
that's definite connection here with
that
isn't that a phoenix
okay maybe in harry potter
it's a phoenix
is there anything that tells us more
about the twin birds
whoops
we are all over the place right now
say ghost flame items
these are all ashes of war
that's poker
can i go here
i know death smoker
good weapon
you guys want a good weapon
uh
did i really wish you could search
did i already pass it
oh there it
is
birds are graveyard fire keepers it said
they
rake out
the ash and remains of the dead from
their kilns
great sword
there's a death
death spoke or greatsword is that what
you're saying
what's it called fire keepers great
sword
yeah when it says kiln i think forge as
well
kill and forge aren't they very similar
things
fire keeper dark souls confirmed what uh
what greatsword are you guys talking
about i'm missing that one
god slayer
sacred sword of the glomide queen who
controlled the godskin apostle before
her defeat the hands of malket the black
wings wielded by the muscles are
channeled from the sword
set the blade ablaze with the god slain
black flame before delivering i mean
that doesn't really tell us much
ritual spear
wind tonight
it's not a spear this is like twin blade
[ __ ]
what what spear is this
oh i did
i go right by it oh there we go thank
you i was looking at ours and i did see
ritual spirit used by priests of old who
were permitted to come
among the death birds
what okay the priests became guardians
of the birds
through the rite of death
which also serves as an oath sworn to
their distant resurrection
trying to think of what that means
the priest
became
guardians of the birds
through the rite of death
which also serves as an oath sworn
to their distant resurrection
the priests are in the wings of the
death birds
in the wings
okay how do i check that
where's a specific death bird
i know of one in caitlyn
where's the church
picture the plague it's like over here
they only come out at night right are
you guys talking about those
no
it'll show up over there that's right
like near the flip side
there it is
i'm gonna go ahead and pause the goddamn
game
and not fight one of these things
everybody shh
shut up
i hate fighting these things man
pausing
you're right
they are in the wings
that's really cool
yeah i'm sure they this thing like spits
them all up in the air
so death ritual spear yes
let me read it one more time i'm
i have to read things twice to
understand them
i think that's pretty normal
i should just kept it equipped
you
is this okay
priests became guardians of the birds to
the right of dutch with all just serves
an almost worn to their distant
resurrection
okay so now that we're in caleb can we
look at the water
we gotta focus man if we we can't go all
over the place that's happened a few
times in these streams where we just
like are talking about everything at the
same time and we have to like
we have to focus
or we end up with nothing
you know
do the ash of war
it's hard not to go off on other stuff
for sure
it's very hard
okay
holy [ __ ]
that's a really cool ash war
yeah it's just a bunch of spears coming
out of the ground
or like raining down from the sky that's
actually really cool
stabby stabby ghost rain
excellent
okay so i'm gonna hide from this bird
it seems the deal between
there's a deal between the priests and
the death birds death birds get power in
return for their round trip from the
dead
kiss him i don't want to kiss this thing
does the bird always
look like corpses or something happen to
them
weren't we talking about divine towers
30 minutes ago
but now we're on to death
yeah what is what is the right of death
referring to
do we know which outer god
the twin bird is the twin bird a god
it is described as an outer god
i mean the thing i have in my brain is
like
are we are we in agreeance that birds
dragons can be considered
birds just just as a thought
it's going back where we started
dragon or bird
dragon or bird
on both sides of the forge
do you guys think the twin bird did this
just took a chunk
you don't have fangs
neither do these
they just have like teeth
look at that
it's kind of a weird dragon man
what kind of dragon just has regular ass
teeth
you're right there are three heads
this doesn't look
tied on right
why is it wrapped up so
weird what is this connected to
the ground okay
[Music]
oh press one in chat if we need dlc
[ __ ] man
there's too much information
there's too much unexplained information
man
one one one one one one one one
[ __ ] now
[Music]
last minute thing that's why it's
wrapped up like that
yeah that's what i was thinking like did
did the fire giant or one of the giants
or whoever like just kind of it looks
unnaturally tied up right there you know
what i'm saying because look at this one
look it's just like that
it's just like a ring around it like
clearly designed and put there right
look at this [ __ ]
the [ __ ] did they do to this thing
i think that's a
interesting take
yeah this this was clearly put
here and is not naturally there
depicted here
which that was just cut off
why is there a split in there we don't
know i'm gonna go ahead and say it's a
dragon that did this i don't know why
i guess next thing we talk about
what the what is this
what is this right here
what is this
you think it hanged above the kiln i
think it was attached i think fair
missoula was attached to the forge
it's not moving it's glowing
it's just ash
hmm
well think about this
i just thought of this
look at this side too
why are the scratches on the inside
you can even see them right here too
let me change the lighting i think i i
think i might have just thought of
something
let me get good lighting here
good enough
there's scratches here as well around
the entire outer
outer side
right there
[Music]
maybe it was grabbing
at one side
and the other
and then was burned
or it could have hooked over and scraped
you need like so we're saying like hot
coal and yeah it's ash but what burned
here
those look natural i don't know what
you're seeing that looks natural about
anything on the inside of this
so i've been i've mentioned this a few
times
um the color
right it kind of has this goldish tint
to it
it reminds me of the two fingers
the three fingers
here right
[Music]
the color
it's a little bit more vibrant
wait
what's in here
nothing
what the heck
yeah it does look more fleshy
kind of looks like scrapes too
hard to say i'm i'm this is where i'm
seeing similarities though is like that
color
that scraping into stone type of thing
[Music]
um
i don't think it's similar enough to
like be like yeah
that's it
the floor is marking on the inside that
looks like words
where
on the ground
three fingers banished
all right let's look at this cutscene
you guys ready for gigachad
hey yeah
it's plastidusak's arena floor
yeah well melania isn't even real so i
don't even care if she hates this
melano doesn't exist
sorry to burst your bubble guys
he's not real
[Music]
what are you saying
his arena was on top of the forge
is that what you're saying
why does michela's needle only work in
his arena
it's a good point
trying to think of all the reasons why
that could be
i don't think these are markings i think
this is just where the fingers like
scraped his hands
fingers
where are you saying the floor was
similar here
at the forge
all right let's go be nakey
let's take a look at that you might be
onto something
i never thought of a
i mean
so when you have a kiln
or a forge shouldn't there be a lid
so this right here right this outer edge
you said is similar to placidus x all
right ingrained in the brain
i'm looking at it looking at it
looking at it
son of a [ __ ]
wait what part of it
all the way on the edge
all right if we die [ __ ] it
we're here for the lore
i'll turn off uh we'll take a better
look now
i mean am i am i tripping i didn't see
it
i didn't see it
i might be tripping though
dog leave me alone
okay now he won't attack me
let's try to eat me man dude those
colors
are you seeing the colors on him because
that looks a lot like the flame of
why are you attacking me still
stop it
thank you
okay where
like here
dude i need a screenshot
my brain
if we're back in time
was this
were you sacrificed
beat
i gotta look again
is this the edge you're talking about
um i made friends with him so he doesn't
attack me now
this arena is weird it it looks like a
lid
at least like right here
i don't think this right here is way
larger than the forge i think all that
is but this
not as much
like right at the pillars here oh
sorry
what happens if i break
i feel bad for tori there's like no shot
he doesn't have a concussion right now
i thought they were respawning
imagine the whole floor starts lifting
up like oh my god
we start spinning like a frisbee
okay i'm looking again
and
we're going back
oh god i can't leave
all right classy we don't need you
anymore i'm sorry
all right what can i kill you with
does anyone use this weapon anymore
remember when this was like the big the
big weapon
when the game came out
i'm not even hurting him
this [ __ ] weak is
for me
that's poker
it's probably pretty good
that's a lot better
10k damage by the way
yeah this weapon is really cool
bye-bye
legend
why does it do so much i'm telling you
that might be the best weapon in the
game no cap on a stack
all right where can i use
uh my thing isn't it over here
i'm completely distracted
why am i trying to do with that
there we go
gotta keep me in check i can go all over
the place man
um
this does look like um like a
locking mechanism like you would you
would link something in right here right
it looks different though
it's definitely different
but this looks like something would lock
in place right here and be the lid
around it
beast men and the path of stone five
fingers of intelligence the one great
the greater will end its elden star the
ceiling of death the twin birds of death
and the two fingers of marika the
eternal
yes tom
all of that
tom [ __ ]
beastman in the path of stone
five fingers of intelligence
the one great the greater will and its
elden star the ceiling of death the twin
birds of death and the two fingers
america the eternal
is that ten
i don't know what you're trying to say
tom but i really appreciate the super
chat thank you very much
thank you thank you thank you
i don't think this is way too small do
you this seems
relative the scale
from what we were just looking at
this is huge
this is pretty massive like it's very
very very big
oh you're giving a timeline okay cool
thank you thank you thank you
that might be one giant
timeline my apologies i'm going mad
trust me i'm going mad too okay
trust me my guy we're all going mad
why are there butterflies here
smoldering butterflies
press one chat if you're going
absolutely mad trying to figure out this
[ __ ] game
it definitely fits the inner ring
but other than that i'm not sure i think
it definitely fits the inner ring
um i mean we can get the camera tool
here
and get a good look at it like maybe if
we look at it like this
it'll kind of help us out it'll be hard
to scale because of different areas but
one two
three four edges
yeah
the thing
the giant the fire giant holds would be
too small for the forge
oh you mean his plate
yeah that would be way too small
way
too small
why does he have that though
they'd be way too small
you spawn enemies or bosses i think i
can but i've never tried it should we
try it
let's spawn a fire giant in here let's
sacrifice his ass
can i do that with this
uh
npc
no
other scripts
yeah they could have scaled it down
that's true but that would be kind of
weird
he deserves to be sacrificed i don't
think i can
i don't know
how to do that
item
no
i don't think i have that mod
npc
npc manager
ah
oh
fire
giant
[Music]
uh
kill
move to player
what does this say
am i tripping
move to player
only affects a live mod
all right well the elden beast is alive
[Music]
right
is it not here
this doesn't work let's not do this
anymore
it looked like the frenzied flame eye
where
like this
it does kind of look like an eyeball but
that i think that's just perspective
let's go uh we were doing this for a
reason and then we completely stopped
what were we doing we were in
the eyes are yellow
right for scale
i think the inner ring here might be
a very similar size
i can't tell how high i am
but i mean
it does
this inner plate here
yep gotta count the pixels boys
this doesn't really help us
that's the whole thing
so high
you know it
my god they didn't even try out here
dude
because we would never see it
can we get much higher we can go as high
as we our heart desires
but let's not do that
because i don't think that's going to
get us anywhere
[Music]
put a boss to scale i can't
i don't know how
i i don't think we're
anywhere that we can say like we're in a
location here like saying we're above
pharah missoula just because all that is
below us
on a platform that is like this i think
doesn't make
sense if it was like
pretty damn rendered out or we could see
like a scene of something else
that would make more sense but uh i
think we're just in an arena and they
have those assets down there
just cuz
like they they do that a lot
yeah like a game development thing
i know from software thinks of this
stuff a lot but they can't do it with
everything you know
we gotta think uh realistically
i have done that taryn and there is
nothing there
no we watched the cut scene like 20
minutes ago
hot air balloon huh hot
oh
bro i don't know
we're all over the place again
we gotta we gotta recenter
yep we're beyond time in a mythical
[ __ ] void of nothingness
yeah i know ethan
chat when your hair gets long
is it normal for it to fall out a lot
it's not a lot it's like
my hair is not falling out a lot i
shouldn't use the word a lot
but like if i comb through my hair like
one strand comes out every time
and my hair goes to like my shoulders
now
it makes me worry like am i going bald
even though i have hair to my shoulders
oh another thing i tried to do yesterday
was at these divine towers
yep i'm bald
bald
okay thank you i was worried
um there are these like lanterns in here
or
i don't know little fire pits
not all of them are lit so i was like
here
trying to do all kinds of fire spells to
like go up there and potentially light
it
nothing worked
[Music]
so i wonder what would happen
asman confirmed
hey asman's got long hair but you know
everyone says he's going bald
it's common all right i won't worry
about it
no worries i guess the other part of the
divine towers that we haven't talked
about yet
you try the fail godfire stuff no i
haven't i don't think i did that
is that uh an incantation
i think
i just tried like torches and [ __ ]
there's probably a lot more i could
could do
spell god [ __ ]
uh
these right
catch flame
oh flame
a lot of pink
body yacht
uh huh
actually i'm gonna replace one of these
this one with
this one
and then
[Music]
is it a dragon thing
wilson
what would be a fel god giants flame
there we go
doubt any of them will do anything me
too dude but you never [ __ ] know
until you try right
i'm gonna go ahead and say no to that
one
nope
oh
get in there boys
sit still under it
imagine
a pot
giants flame fire pot
imagine
imagine
need more of these but let's just not
miss
nope
maybe i gotta go above it
nope
dude the way that interacted with that i
thought it was it
did you see it just hone in on that
i put it out here
okay dude i was about to bust
imagine you have to have the flame of
frenzy in you to get this to work as
well
hey teflon how are you
yeah i tried torches yesterday nothing
did anything i'm out of fpe pain
[Music]
look above the flame whose face is that
um the face is on the defiant like the
divine towers have the same faces as
uh what's on the side of the forge of
the giants
we have definitely figured that out
alexander went to lava to get stronger
killing himself basically
it's a cool attack
like yeah to heal his uh crack
you know that's what that's what you do
in a kiln or when you're uh when you're
a [ __ ] pot you know
did you guys take ceramics in high
school
it like that
wait whoa whoa
oh another thing i noticed yesterday
[Music]
which turned out to not be the case for
every single one of the divine towers
or just don't have lids
yes they do
you close the lids to a forge in
ceramics
don't you
this [ __ ] just don't stay open
that's a kiln
okay calm down holy [ __ ]
bro stop confusing kills and fortunes
gorgeous okay god calm down
just you have to take off your armor to
get flame frenzied but vike is melted in
the shape of fingerprints
were the black stripes floating down
uh
[Music]
i don't know i thought it was dust
i'm not jumping into the forge
we did find out america was rata gone on
stream
nope they just kind of go down
[Music]
why they use
i mean do they use meteorites as like
gravity stuff
have [ __ ] like work in here
what was i going to say before i came
down here for a reason
i thought yesterday when i was looking
at this
that like these are lit right
like whatever these are
this also looks like a forge or the
forge of the giants
kinda i think it's just a bold design
when you look out the window here
i thought they like looked at each
divine tower
but that's not the case for each one so
that's not
that didn't really lead me anywhere
someone looks at two
it was like one i think it was a lorena
one that didn't look at anything
[Music]
is this the forbidden area
man when it's not all dark and
scary looking it's kind of underwhelming
the [ __ ]
[Music]
it's like yep
excellent
all right well now i don't know where to
go from here
that's why it's forbidden
it's underwhelming
pretty view
you know when i first played the game
like when i first started
and mel and i was like have you heard of
the finger maidens
they serve the two fingers
and you actually hadn't met a two
fingers yet did you guys ever think
that they would actually be two fingers
i thought it'd just be a name for
something but they went very literal
with that
very literal
with that
it won't let me up here
hmm
i mean what is that tornado like what's
the point of it
yeah and they're hairy through good
point
i think melania's divine tower here is
the only one that um
has one of these broken
oh you guys want to talk about the three
wolves
is that our next thing
dude my brain is fried right now that's
not where we want to go
[Music]
three wolves walk into a bar
all right who is this
tell me now
let's get a nice cinematic shot
we could talk about this tomorrow
this is a cool shot
if i weren't butt ass naked
granola america ronnie
you know what we're gonna do because it
seems to be
a good topic
let's talk about this tomorrow
we'll do another laura hunting stream
tomorrow
i'm [ __ ] gassed and i'm starving
i also streamed like
seven hours yesterday on twitch
okay
it's wolf girl
clearly ass still all right there we go
um couple of things
i got a surprise for you guys
yes i'm also on twitch
i stream like random stuff over there if
you guys are interested in that links in
the bio
um
i got a surprise though
that i have no idea if you'll like or
not
i think you will
and i don't know whether to do it on
here or on twitch i haven't decided yet
but
i would like to do a hundred percent
play through
of bloodborne
so yes candy it's candy
ancient elven ring
ancient elden ring slash roots of death
so the great tree
i haven't played bloodborne in a long
time tom thank you very much dude
we'll talk about that more tomorrow come
by tomorrow but thank you man thanks for
all the super chats you're very nice
very kind
um yeah should i do that here or on
twitch
i'm not sure
say i love you and your positivity a lot
of people
uh really take people at their worst and
assume the worst thanks for being one of
my favorite streams content creators
that's very nice for you to say stephen
thanks for being here dude i'm glad you
enjoy it
thanks lewis
glad you like it
up to me huh so the other part about
that is uh i started a vod channel
so like this stream and all the rest of
the um
the lore hunting streams are gonna go up
on the vod channel so if you guys ever
want to watch those back
that's also linked in the description if
you're curious
um
so there's that i started that
go check it out
i've just been told by so many other
creators that you should always have a
vaude channel like a totally different
channel
so
we'll go with that
um but tomorrow we will talk more about
these three wolves and whoever this
woman is
we can look deep into that
oh we're already done today sub-zero
sorry man
gonna be a short one i got some stuff i
need to do today and then i'm gonna
stream on twitch tonight as well
so everything's down in the description
guys go check them out uh
you know i'll obviously edit these down
into
um
shorter videos to put up on the normal
youtube channel things like that
sub-zero if you missed the stream
um go to
[Music]
the vod channel it's gonna go up on
there okay
okay
good spike viewer counts you could give
awards to vid worthy discoveries
it sounds
interesting
what time tomorrow around the same time
like 11am cst
this is mickela all right
we'll talk about it tomorrow guys i
appreciate the conversation today that
was a lot of fun i think we found a lot
of really cool stuff that draws
comparisons for sure
i had a lot of fun
so if you got here late go check out the
vod channel in the description
appreciate it if you did
thanks for being here thanks for all the
love super chats
subscribers things like that we are
really close to 100 000 subscribers
which i would poop my pants over
so let's just keep going keep working
and we will eventually get there
we'll be back tomorrow um if you're
interested in some random [ __ ] on twitch
i'm not sure if i'm gonna stream
bloodborne on twitch or on here i'll
probably stream it on here
i think that would be better
um
but maybe on twitch so go check
everything out i'd appreciate it uh
and i'll see you guys tomorrow
have a great rest of your day and i'll
see you then
peace out